all right y'all let's do it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
your
absolutely favorite podcast
[Music]
with me
what's up y'all welcome back uh today is
a
guest we got a guest on the the show
today we got mr moths gibrani back for
his second time to talk about his
special that he shot in dubai
and we have some shop top shop talk and
we
talk about social media we just go into
a bunch of things as comics do when they
get together so
i thank you guys for being here for that
uh remember i game every
day on twitch eric griffin gaming but
i just want to thank y'all for being
with them within
all right i know i love doing the intro
it's my favorite part of the podcast
um but yeah we're back with a guest uh
it's guest time i occasionally gonna do
bonus episodes during the week i think
when i do a guest i'm gonna have a bonus
solo on wednesday
uh so that's how i do that but anyways i
hope you enjoyed this episode and like i
said again you can catch me on twitch
eric griffin gaming
i do that all the time um i appreciate
your comments your support i do have a
patreon even though nobody really
supports it even though i don't do
enough on it i was gonna do stuff with
rachel but now she started her own
vlog so i can't even like put those
videos on patreon so i gotta figure out
what the hell i'm gonna do on patreon
and
you know what i am it's time for me to
like
really get like somebody
i i i say this all the time but now this
is real this time okay officially
i need an intern somebody that lives in
la
that is looking to help me out and you
know it could turn into
obviously turned into paid some money i
don't know it's not like i make a ton
doing this but
i need somebody to like so i could take
the podcast to the next level so i am
looking out for that right now so if
you're out there you can send me an
email eric at errorgriffin.com
i don't need resumes i just need like a
little blurb like just send me like
yo this is what i do this is what i can
do this is what i want to offer and this
is
you know this is what i've done before
and let's see if we can get into a
dialogue back and forth and see how it
goes and then maybe we'll test it out by
i'll send some video footage to this
person they'll put it together what they
think and then maybe we'll like
have a little contest with me and like
okay who
what how do you want it to be put
together like this or like that guy or
this guy then we'll have people vote let
me
do it like that but i don't know but
again i need help with doing that kind
of stuff
but anyways i'm not going to go too long
of an intro right now with all this
stuff so let's just i have a nice long
interview with miles giovanni so let's
get right
into it and thanks for being here on the
podcast
uh ladies and gentlemen welcome again to
the podcast for his second
time now my my i'm talking
long time friend you say this a lot but
this is like
for real for real long time friend going
back to the days of
just starting comedy uh watch the first
episode to find out our origin story
we're going to talk about other things
now but again welcome to the podcast my
friend mr maz gibrani
thanks for having me man i feel like
number two i don't know who i'm in
competition with but i know on saturday
night live they have
tom hanks steve martin there's a
alec baldwin they have a handful of guys
who posted it 10 20 times
so i'm a number two i hope i work my way
towards
whatever that number is i know so
we're just old i mean because this is
because the way things are going this is
going to be the only form of
entertainment that we're going to
that we're going to have dude i already
feel super old
you're on clubhouse right don't even get
me started
on this clubhouse you know what's so
crazy about it because we're around the
same age
so like when we were growing up we had
to
to like for me to hit you up i would
call you
and we would talk on the phone so these
guys said
hey let's go retro and make the young
people think it's cool
they're literally just talking on the
phone
eric it's the craziest thing ever so
that's exactly how i got in so so
you know my boy tehran tyron opens for
me on the road
he's funny he's just a great guy all
around and he's
charismatic i always got something going
on so tehran is like my
lifeline to the youth because he knows
he looks up
yeah you know he's in his he's in his uh
early to mid 30s so he hit me up he's
like yeah
they're doing a comedy show on something
called clubhouse and i was like what
and it's exactly what you just said it's
so counterintuitive
when these people in silicon valley come
up with this site these ideas because
as as comedians or as you know on the
clubhouse you got comedians you got
uh lecturers you've got life coaches
you've got
yeah yeah and you know financial
advisors whatever it is
you would think the idea is to be seen
i want to be seen like that's part of it
you're going oh how do we how does zoom
get how do we improve on
zoom how do we improve go to the next
level these guys go let's go the other
way let's get on that phone call you and
i are on a phone call and people just
listening in
and i did it and it was so much fun yeah
it's ridiculous how many people are yeah
yeah
it's fun and also and also it's
addicting i've ended up on the comedy
room a couple of times
one time i ended up on the comedy room
and i stayed there for a couple like
maybe two three hours
next day i just logged on to see what's
going on
that same room was still going yeah man
well i mean that's the thing too about
it too like if
you if i just randomly call you you
might not even take the call
but if i sent you a link on clubhouse
and it's like
uh saturday here's the things we're
going to do on saturdays
and where should you go and where should
you not go you might be like oh this is
interesting hey eric how you doing i
mean it's just
it's so ridiculous to me but like it is
what it is you know
you also know you also know there are
some people like i'm listening i think i
think
girls women in general now this is a
generalization but i think there's some
truth to it women in general will hang
out on a phone call longer than dudes
will in general
so when you have a clubhouse and there's
20 women on it and there's 10 dudes on
it and 10 of the
you know eight of those dudes are single
and just
hanging out anyway at their home or
wherever it is and they're insomniacs
and they're comedians
you know how it is at the comedy club
sometimes you keep talking and then you
look around like oh my god it's two in
the morning and people are and there's
something
there's a group that's still going to go
out and eat so yeah once you
once you combine all those people
together you could
i i'm i'm always the first person to
leave and it's funny because it says
leave quietly but it's hard to leave
quietly when you've been
talking talking and talking and then
just be like plop but you got to do it
because you got i got a life
what i don't like what i don't like is i
had to turn this off it's like you get
the notification
and you go to click just to get to the
app and then it just puts you in a room
you know yeah yeah yeah so i'm just in
this room and somebody said eric griffin
what's up and i'm like i didn't want to
do that
i don't want it i don't like you people
that's funny
but i will tell you i will tell you i
feel
at least a few times i've done it it
feels for us for people in our
life uh in our in our in our you know
careers
and what we do it's been a very it's a
very
um lively
kind of you know like for example on
twitter on
instagram on facebook i'll post
something i don't know how many people
are real
i don't know how people are fake i don't
know what's going on but clubhouse feels
like right now it's really hot and you
can
get either a it could help your social
media following it could also help
i met a guy who i hope it's gonna work
out but he's
um really good at like turning existing
videos on
like comedy videos into passive income
on social media and he seems legit so
i'm talking to him about hey how do i
take my seven specials or whatever it is
that i have
right and boom boom boom yeah yeah yeah
you know totally uh yeah that's well
that's the wave of the future i don't
know i mean it's just like
you know what i i think that being old
and i talked about this on my
when i do solo episodes but you know i
love to talk bounce it off someone else
who understands where i'm coming from
but
you know it's like i think that you
really
are looked at as old when you don't
change with the times you know yes so
you look at social media and you might
think like
i'm good with facebook that's when
you're old
you know what i'm saying when you're
like you know it's like you already had
a you had trouble going from
you had trouble going from myspace to
facebook and so you're still like i miss
my myspace that's when you're like
you're old
but you know because but things are
moving so fast right now that they're
becoming obsolete before i can even
oh let me get on this and then it's like
it's already gone you know what i mean
like
this year this year was like 10 years
of technology and change in one
so right when it started i remember i
was talking to some guy patreon he's
like
you gotta you gotta put up a patreon i
tried to do that i didn't feel
comfortable asking people for money at
that time
i kind of took my foot back and then the
next thing you know like you said it's
like
oh then cameo and then it's and then
it's this in clubhouse and
and i think as as our as performers as
writers as artists as comedians
i think you're right because i look at
guys
when we started out at the comedy store
there were guys who were coming around
who were older and their style
even the way they dressed yeah yeah
everything they were talking about was
still
you know we were there early 2000s they
were still doing jokes from the 90s and
80s
or or their style was that and you're
going oh my god this poor guy
is collecting the 15 check and then i
don't know where else they're
making a living maybe they're doing the
road or whatever but then you look at
guys that you want to emulate
and you look at a guy like a jerry
seinfeld or a chris rock
or even you know um you know even
people like kevin neal and some of these
guys that are older than us
that have been out there but they're
still writing they're still creating so
then they have their
their older fans but they also because
you and i both know
we were comedy fans first so my kids 12
now my
my kids love listening to stand up and
they'll be listening
to netflix as a joke or whatever and
brian regan comes on and john panette
and whoever comes on they're
into it so i think the key
is to keep writing to keep trying to
stay relevant even like like you were
talking about clubhouse last night i
ended up on
there's these rooms they get together
and they go shoot your shot have you
heard about shoot your shot you know
what that is
no shoot your shot it's basically it's
like a it's almost like a spin the
bottle it's like a pickup game so right
that's what they all get yeah they all
get in one room and they'll bring
somebody up from the audience like
who do you want to shoot your shot at oh
i want to shoot my shot at whoever the
girl is and oh okay and then if she says
yeah okay fine go ahead and dm me then
the guy's got to go and dm her and they
whatever happens from there it happens
or they go i want to shoot a shot for
friendship or whatever it is
so they were doing that i didn't know i
i kind of knew what it was but i kind of
didn't but tehran and max
were on the list i was like let me see
what these guys are up to i go in there
and they're telling shot shot a shoot
shot at
well no i started laughing i was like i
was like what the hell am i doing in
here and then jokingly i was like listen
my wife and i
we are actually in need of if if you are
good at
cleaning or plumbing or you have any
applicable
skills shoot your shot we'll take you
into our family like we'll take you
but but i did feel like as i'm looking
at all these people
i go oh my god these people are in their
mid-20s late 20s and i go wow that makes
you feel old
i'm going to be 49 this month and it
makes you feel old and
and they probably look at me as like an
uncle type or whatever
but regardless when it comes time to
creating and being on stage and talking
about stuff if you see my show now i'm
talking about
all the [__] going down under covet i
got jokes about instagram i got jokes
about clubhouse i got just
i'm i'm i'm tr but that's i'm not just
doing it to like
be hip i'm doing it because it interests
me so you got to stay interested in
what's happening
well i mean okay i i agree i agree with
you and
but the thing is that you have to
remember too is that just because we're
trying to stay relevant doesn't mean the
young people want us to be relevant
you know there are certain things that
it's like they go ah what is the 49 year
old doing on tick-tock you know what i
mean
there's a certain thing that kids young
people are kind of like hey can we have
our thing
you know what i mean like this is our
thing like there's a certain
to me there's there's an age cap on
certain things you know it's like
coachella you know you know you're 50 at
coachella they're looking at you like
what are you doing here
you go go to burning man or whatever you
know even if it's not even if it's a not
right attitude
i feel like there's a little bit of that
going on you know it's like it's like
when that when
[__] was a big thing you know everybody
was you know and you had all these like
women on you know putting posts up oh my
whop i mean i think there's a certain
point where young people are like yeah
you're beyond your past whop age
well i'm but i'm going to counter that
and look at like jlo
and you look at some of these other
people i'm not saying
denial i'm not saying being denial of
who you are because also as comedians
our job is to be a little curmudgeon
league and so
i have also the past few years i've gone
to i went i went to berkeley for
undergrad and they've asked me to do me
and samuel bates sammy's also an alumni
from there an alum alumni i don't know
which one was which
alum um so we've we've done the we've
done comedy shows for the incoming
freshman class the past i don't know
four years
which is a trip when you do that because
it really makes you do the math so the
first time i did it
i did the math and i thought to myself
wow i was at cal
i came into cal in 1989 another summer
brothers and sisters but it was 1989 and
uh that dates you too
it dates me but i did the math and i was
like okay
if i had someone my age
come and talk to me and do a comedy show
for me in 1989 that would have meant
they were they
they they had been at cal i think it was
like 1959 or something
like 30 years ago and so in my mind i'd
be sitting in the audience going
who is this old mofo
no they you know but but then but that
but then what i did was because i was
intimidated by that by the way yeah
cause a lot of times people ask you that
those comedians you ever get nervous
i go i get nervous it's not i don't get
nervous when i'm in a different country
if i'm in a different country in front
of a bunch of parents i could be in
timbuktu
and do parenting material and they'd be
like yeah my kids are the same you know
i get nervous when i'm talking to a
bunch of 12 year olds or
f 5 year olds so the generational thing
um but what i was able to do and this is
something i think we learn as we go
was to try and meet them in a
conversation that we had in common so
there was a lot of talk about
you know doing some crowd work and going
you know
do you guys like like i i was trying to
i was trying out this joke about
how i realized i i could never be a
doctor
when they brought out the frog on that
petri dish in fifth grade and the
formaldehyde and i was like that is
disgusting
and i go what do you want me to do we
want you to cut it open and pull out a
fly i'm like are you out of your goddamn
mind
yeah and and as part of that joke i was
kind of
making fun of saying i said i don't even
know if they do that anymore because
maybe it's cruel to frogs like what are
you guys using now you dissect bread
what do you guys do
and so that i think
you know they're smart enough at that in
those teenage years
to get that and i'm not pretending to be
like i'm not going like so anyway guys
you know what's up hipsters you know
you know you understand i'm saying as
long as you got your point of view i get
what you're saying but there is a little
bit of delusion to what you're saying
right now
i mean i'm just being i'm just being 100
with you because i'm living
i'm sorry because i'm living it too but
listen you
are the old guy and there are
a lot of young people in the crowd who
are gonna be like
oh this is my dad and it's like oh it's
cool you know it's like when you go they
go
like oh you're doing dad jokes like what
does that really mean when you say dad
jokes
i mean that's what you you you try to
you go like let me stop doing that
because you know let me like you don't
even realize you're doing it because you
think like no this is cool what am i
doing
like but then it takes a young person to
go to you and go oh yeah like i do some
stuff in my podcast
sometimes i get all these these beats
get sent to me for these these
musicians you know and then i'll like
impromptu rap on there
and then i'll see the comments and
people go i'm here for this dad [__]
that's what they say
and i'm thinking about it i go and i go
oh i totally get it because yeah
i'm the old guy doing my thing you know
and what i'm saying there's nothing
wrong with that but what i'm saying is
what i'm saying is like there that
generational gap
it it it could be
it can't be taken away we just have to
live in it i like when a
person comes you know what i mean
because they're laughing for different
reasons man
but also [__] those [__]
because
there's always some like judgmental
little
[__] who's gonna be like and i'll be
like you know what when i was
10 years old i was listening to bill
cosby and
laughing i was listening to george
carlin with his gray hair
and what he was saying was relevant so
you and i could still be social
commentators and we're still going to
get laughed at by some young
punk who's like uh but there's also
going to be a lot of kids who are fans
of comedy
as long as you and i aren't doing like
you know as long as like the whole set
isn't
i don't know uh you know like like you
know again
going back to there were some guys who
we would see at the clubs
who were doing stuff and you're going
god this guy's got a right i mean
right that's one of one of i think one
of eddie murphy's biggest
obstacles right now is what's he going
to talk about when he comes back he's
this
super you know
yeah so so part of that though is to nip
it in the bud
right is to get i'll give you an example
i just did an
outdoor show at some like it's an it's
an
outdoor show in hollywood it's a club
mark ceratella runs it
it literally is a nightclub that had an
outdoor patio that now they've turned
that outdoor patio into a comedy show oh
i i've been to that they canceled it
because
i was there doing a show there yeah you
know how it's like broadcasted
out onto los cienega yeah yeah yeah well
the that big expensive building that's
13 000
a month they called the cops and then i
was on stage and he comes up and goes
this is the last comic ah that's funny
wait no if you were in los angeles mine
was on
in hollywood oh but regardless the fact
is as i was doing it so it's jeff
ross it was it was taylor tomlinson talk
about young
and funny right yeah then it was jeff
ross
then it was uh jeremy piven and then it
was me now
i'm looking around the room and i was
talking to jeff ross about i go jeff i'm
looking at this crowd because they're a
club crowd
and i go this reminds me of dublins i go
these are the
this is the dublin's crowd back in the
day when everyone was all hipstery and
there's
people with like you know people look
like there's a lot of johnny depp
looking type dudes
but in their 20s and 30s and there's a
lot of like young girls i mean there was
a couple of young girls in the back
who were clearly drunk who clearly like
knew the owner of the place
and because jeff brought jeff brought up
jeff's like i'm gonna roast somebody and
he goes here you guys come up so he
brought up
gene simmons's son i guess jeff knows
him or something
um with his girlfriend
and the girlfriend nick simmons is his
name
what's that nick simmons yeah nick
simmons
so he brings them up to roast them and
these two girls are in the back and
they're
drunk and i guess they know nick
simmons's girlfriend so
every time jeff says something funny
these girls go yeah
yeah and just like disrupting to the
point where i heard some
some lady on in the audience kind of
turned around was like would you just
just shut the [__] up but they
were too drunk to even notice and i'm
sitting there watching this and i'm like
oh my god all right
these guys are going up they're having
good sets and i'm just and it's cold as
hell
and i'm going okay how what am i going
to how am i going to like
is is my set going to translate here
tonight because it's very hipstery and i
just come from the laugh factory where i
did a zoom show
and that translated because it was a lot
of like oh my god under the lockdown
life has been like this
whatever yeah so you and i know it's
like after 22 years of doing this
you find the key to relate to any
audience
so before i went up jeremy's doing his
set
and part of his set is how
bitter he is at like john stamos and at
the rock and some of these other guys
because they're working
and he's like something something like
he ran into most sustainable
something stupid to him but you know
they're friends he's just being funny
about it
and he goes stamos said this this and
this and i was like
i got three emmys [__] you know
and then and then and then and then
jeremy in a self-deprecating way i'll be
like god i'm so bitter i'm so bitter
so that was my key i was like wait a
minute this [__] has three emmys
and he's bitter
i go i haven't even lasted to season two
yeah so that became the joke right so as
soon as i went up
i was like and so it doesn't matter if
you're young old doesn't matter who's in
that room
i went up and i was like jeremy how many
homies do you guys think i got three i
go dude
i'm a i'm a middle eastern actor we die
in season one
yeah you know the hell you complaining
about and
so all of that to say i totally agree
with you i'm not saying because the
worst thing you can be
is and it's sad we've seen this we've
seen guys
either at comedy clubs but you usually
see them in like bars and nightclubs
where you're like oh my god that dude is
too old to be hanging out with that crew
we've seen that yeah
and that's a bad situation what is this
what is self-awareness that like you
know sometimes we just get lost in i
mean i think that being
at like for instance being at the comedy
store
you know when you cause look there's a
new generation that are coming up and
you know
and you hear a lot of the older comics
all continuously talking about cancer
culture and everybody's too sensitive
and then the young people are like nah
we're not sensitive
so that's an example of not moving with
the times
yes you know it's a perfect example not
like it's like
you know it's like that and that's
something that is hard to understand
for like people of our age group
sometimes just to be like why are you so
sensitive you know but you know
when they're just saying like well maybe
we don't like you know the things you're
saying
you know what i mean you know it's like
it's really really for example you know
it's funny to me like you know like
chappelle
you know he did that um you saw the clip
about how he's talking about comedy
central you know
yeah and it's funny because he said to
like about netflix you know he's like
they he said it didn't make me feel good
is what he said about
why they were playing the chappelle show
and to me i thought to myself well i
guess that's what the transgender people
are saying to him
your jokes don't make me feel good you
know what i mean good point
yeah you know so it's like it's one of
those things you just kind of go uh oh
you know what i mean
but you know it's just like it's one of
those moments where
you just go it's like you know we are of
a certain age and we have our way and
then there is a sort of wiseness that
people want to walk listen to that and
and their demographic is not 18 to 25
but that's but you know when you're in
hollywood that's the only demographic
they're going for but comedy just
doesn't necessarily work like that so
there's always like a disconnect and the
greats can get past it you know
but even the greats to get past it
there's still going to come a time where
people are going to be like oh that
guy's too old and they're going to have
a different audience it's not going to
be mainstream you know
well let me say this let me say this
first of all you're absolutely right
that's a good point you hit on so
first of all um it doesn't matter how
great of a comedian you are
as a human being if you're not evolving
you are out of out of touch so we have
like i don't know if you follow mandy
potenkin and his wife
on twitter their son has been
documenting
their lockdown and it's the funniest
sweetest and yet most sincere and
charming thing
you'll see because he gets them arguing
he gets them doing whatever it is
and they are leaning into their age but
at the same time
they're very hip it's kind of like the
betty white syndrome right betty white
100 years old but we were like i love
betty white i want you know kids
i want to hang out with betty white so
similarly if you're open and willing to
change as you just said
sorry but uh if you have to be
willing and willing to do that and i'll
tell you
um um what that reminded me of a little
bit because you talk about this cancel
culture and how communities go oh no you
know
so i had a guy on my podcast
uh back to school with major brony watch
it find it anywhere you can
um i had on my podcast this guy named
jordan shapiro he's an author
and he's written child you know kid
books and one of the books was all about
how
um screen time for kids isn't as bad as
we think it is
and the second thing he wrote is called
um how to be a feminist dad
but really it's about how to be a
respectful and what you just said
open human being to other people's
points of views
and one thing he told me that blew my
mind i hadn't even thought about this he
goes we all go through our days
as the hero of our own stories but we
forget
that we are the villain in other
people's stories or the side character
yeah and we need to remind ourselves
that they're the heroes of their own
stories
and that sometimes we gotta open
ourselves up and go wait a minute
let me see how i play into your story so
the way it worked for me was i said oh
my god that just made me realize my
little beautiful 10 year old daughter
every once in a while i will have you
know cooked whatever cleaned the dishes
done the laundry taken the dog for a
walk taking the kids to practice blah
blah blah blah blah
finally put my feet up on my bed
open up my twitter it's me time and my
daughter comes out and goes daddy and i
go
what i roll my eyes yeah yeah
and i was like what an [__] and i go
you know what i'm gonna start working a
little bit on realizing
she's got her own day going she's got
her she's the hero of her story
and i gotta rather than feeling
frustrated i gotta go
what's going on how can i be you know
service to you here because i love you
yeah
and so similarly what you just said this
cancel culture thing you're right
when these young people come at you and
they go hey we don't
we're not we're not too sensitive we
just feel like you're old and outdated
or you are saying they're saying you're
just being mean or you're just being
like
pick any of those adjectives that they
like to use like okay we're being
misogynistic you're being mean you're
being uh
you know like you're insensitive to uh
pick a group you know what i mean and
then it's like we come from this era was
like
well we're just telling jokes this is
comedy and it's like so now we're you
know
what you know what i really feel is
cancer culture has always been present
they just didn't have a voice or a
platform to put it out there
that's what i'm starting to realize you
know because like let's say there was
twitter and instagram and all this stuff
even during the days of george carlin
there might like he for sure would have
been somebody who would have people have
been like i don't like what you know
he he's saying this about this and you
know the christians would have got on
him the you know yeah but it just wasn't
present so now that
there's a voice for all of this and
there's a you know platforms i mean you
know maybe it's something that's always
been there i don't know but
you know i just feel like uh it's
something to think about you know
as these movements come by like you know
me too was a big one it was a big one to
just sit back as a guy and be like
oh yeah maybe saying this joke like this
i didn't realize how it's making these
people feel because i don't i'm
you know you know now you go okay so as
a comic you got to be a little smarter
you got to be a little
you know more savvy in how you do your
joke to say the same joke to get the
same
point across so amen and you got to be
open to
their because you know there's people
who just blindly just will see a word
and take it out of context and be like
oh you said this and that like i i
on my uh netflix special i did a couple
jokes
that at least to me seemed like they
were pro lgbtq
yeah but there was some guy who kind of
jumped on it and
having had chappelle do some jokes he's
like oh netflix here's another
netflix comedian making fun of the lgbtq
i'm like did you listen to what i said
i'm trying to yeah yeah
i'm trying to tell my community to be
open-minded to lgbtq you're not
listening to what i'm saying
that said i would be open for a
conversation with this person if they
said to me but yeah but the way you say
it it can be misconstrued yeah and you
know what
go ahead and go ahead no no no no no
because i just cause i i it's just i
have something with this too with that
go go and i don't know
yeah no i'm just it's like this is when
you can't worry about individuals
because there's no point in us trying to
convince someone because they've already
been convinced
they are convinced they've said you are
now uh
whatever you know you're this is hate
speech to them
and and trying to rationalize it with
them it's like no no i'm talking about
this
you can't like at a certain point we
also have to be like this is me i'm
going to do what i do
and you move on because there's always
going to be people like that because
they live for that
there are people that literally live for
trying to
make your words fit their narrative
you're absolutely right and
and i like what you said which is you
got to be you this is me and that's what
i was getting at actually as well which
is
ultimately be your authentic self in
in in in in a in a a convoluted way one
could say that's what trump did
and made him so likable to his group
because he was his authentic self for
sure similarly for sure
not just his group by the way what's
that that's not just his group by the
way you
you personally know a lot of people that
secretly support trump
they don't want to say it out loud what
i'm saying is by being your authentic
self
i think people go okay that's who that
guy is you know at least i know
who that guy is and i could either latch
on or not latch on and for us for
example
i feel like one thing i've gotten from
this younger generation and i want to
try doing it is
so when you and i first started out
back then i was a big fan of peter
sellers from the pink panther and i
still think he's
super talented yeah one of the great
comedic actors one of the great
communities
of all time yeah he's just so in the
pink panther he plays a french guy
in the party he plays an indian guy in
dr strangelove he plays multiple
different backgrounds and so
i'm watching that i'm like oh my god i
want to do that i want to play
mexican i want to play indian i want to
play all this stuff and back then
we were able to and we were doing it and
we'd do with the accent and
really you would try as an actor i think
now but now cancer culture is like you
need to hire an
indian person to be an indian person and
you need to hire us like
so should we get a serial killer to play
a serial killer or is there any acting
at all
but that's but that's what i'm getting
at first of all in my opinion if you
watch the party
he's got an indian accent but really his
character is the lovable hero of the
film so it's almost like he's doing in
my opinion
he's also even though he's in brown face
he
is trying his best to do
a positive character there and at that
point probably that movie got made
because peter sellers was on board so
let's face it there was no
east indian actor that could have in
hollywood they would have made that
movie around so let's just put that
aside
and so when you get that part when you
get like i played an indian on a tv show
for abc
i tried to make him fun and lovable and
i tried to make
like the accent wasn't the joke i wasn't
like oh let's laugh at these people
but some people will construe it as that
they'll say no you are making fun of
those
so with that said i've actually evolved
as an actor
and now when i talk to my agents and
stuff like that when it's time to create
stuff i go i want to be as close
and authentic to who i am in my
characters
sure i play serial killer but how about
if i play him like this
as opposed to having to do something you
know that's
that's far away from who i am but that's
a creative that's a creative artistic
choice that people are going to make
whatever
and however popular a person is they can
overcome certain things
but what we're finding out now that's
what i'm saying there is a segment of
the population who it doesn't matter we
can rationalize this all we want
like we're trying to make sense here
we're trying to say like hey you know
not everybody's reasonable not everybody
wants to use common sense people like
being outraged there is a certain love
for that
on the internet people like people like
finding things to be like
this is ridiculous i can't believe they
hired a
black person to play this or i can't
believe they hired a you know you know
there's people that they have
their things and and they feel justified
you know it's like when you have a
character in a book they have some
beloved book
you know like hunger games you know
here's an example
and then they made uh one of these
characters a little black girl and there
were people who were like she's not
black in the book why is she a black you
know
so they have their justification for
that then there's other people be like
well that seems racist why are you like
you know and then
everybody feels right and so it's just
like that's what i'm saying is like
trying to navigate and understand that
is that is now the challenge
you know because because because like i
remember having a joke about i had this
joke uh
when i first first started i was talking
about i don't drink
and every time i go out i have to be the
designated driver you know
and i would say you know when you're
designated driver at the end of the
night it's like taking care of
autistic kids they're just all over the
place you know
so to me i to me that's like of course
you're gonna have people oh you know my
son is autistic and
this is like and in my mind i
rationalize it like isn't it tough
taking care of him
you know like like for me you should
laugh at the joke the most
because you know how it is to take care
of an autistic kid you know but
there are people who are like you can't
do jokes like that they don't like
how you said didn't you hear what i said
didn't you listen to what i said
it's like so like me getting into an
argument with
this is just it is what it is you know
so sometimes
you know sometimes it's just it's a wash
well it's yeah it's it's again you're
being your authentic self and also
knowing listen
the other thing that we have to navigate
in this world not just us but everybody
is what you put out in public and what
you might say in private
right so you know there's certain words
or certain like i don't i try not to
cuss too much in public i mean on stage
i'll do it sometimes
but i just you know if i'm on certain
you know on instagram live i try not to
cuss too much because i know that video
is going to be up
and if my kids see it or whatever it's
like now i'm a foul mouth you know what
i'm saying and not not to say i hate
that as a matter of fact i love saying
[__]
and sometimes and by the way sometimes
these dudes
because during your ig live you have a
troll come on you know
so i love cussing them out because it
feels good because but that said like in
private i
love i love cussing so whatever that is
there's certain things that you
nowadays you feel like okay i can say
that in private
and i got to be careful what i say in
public but i think ultimately the the
thing
in my mind is as long as you're your
authentic self
and you're not trying to pretend to be
somebody
else right if you're not trying you some
people
you know is it's the the moment you
start
doing things based on market research
then you're not the artist anymore right
now you're a jukebox you're taking
requests now you're
whoever it is that your advisor said you
know you got to put out more videos that
are like this
and you got to you know i'm like oh god
i hate that too they hit you up like hey
you know you know this person's doing
this you should do that i can't stand
that but here's my one pushback
for on what you're saying uh but i think
we're gonna be in agreement
being your authentic self doesn't mean
that
that is a viable thing for entertainment
you know because i give you examples
something like
like i have more respect for south
african
uh racism than i have for american
racism
because at least they are they they let
you know apartheid was like
we don't like black people and we want
them living over there it wasn't
it wasn't underground it was like in
your face you know right
right south african racism is their
authentic self
you know what i mean but they don't mean
that it's
it doesn't mean that it's like okay well
that's not good for the sake of being
being good you know just because
somebody's doing that and it and it just
goes to like
what you're because what the thing
you're saying is uh and by the way i'm
saying i don't like racist and i have to
like clarify my words
i'm just using an analogy of just being
like you know you know
you have to say that because these
idiots are going to write comments no
matter what i say they're still going to
write comments but
eric griffin likes i know i know i know
so the thing is it's like
the thing is it's like being your
authentic self and what you're talking
about about
public life not everything you say needs
to go on the internet
like this chick i was looking up her
name just so i get it right gina
carr carano you know the one that got
kicked off the mandalorian
you know she had this twitter what this
was oh man it was a big story man she
had these twitter posts that she
uh instagram or twitter about uh
comparing uh how people
i i don't even i don't want to like mess
it up but you know
they made her out to be anti-semitic
okay okay all right and when i read the
thing i was like
i thought it was a stretch to go that
far with it
because i actually understood what she
was trying to say it just wasn't a good
analogy in the same way that my
south african analogy might not be
somebody might be
you know if anybody can misconstrue
things then you might have to think to
yourself maybe i shouldn't say it like
that
well she said some things that she
probably would say would have to say
with people who are
have nuance in their conversation and
can push back and be like what do you
mean this when you just put out stuff
people can't
interact to get like the root of it so
she put this thing out and she got fired
you know wow yeah she got fired she's
now off the mandalorian forever
and this is one of these moments where
it's like you don't got to say every
your every single thought
especially political thoughts when
you're a public figure
on the internet just it's not your and
you know
sometimes if you let it because listen
there's also this funny
you know desire obviously for to get
more likes to get more followers to get
more whatever that is so in your mind
there's there's been times where i'm
like
oh yeah that's a good one let me put
that out there and
and and like you said if i step away
from it for
you know 12 hours 24 hours sometimes i
come back and i go ah that's not really
worded the best way
or or or at least run it by somebody say
it out loud to somebody you love
and know and go what do you think of
this and if they go oh that's hilarious
and you trust them then perhaps you you
go for it but that said it's just
you're you're absolutely right you you
don't have to put out every thought
i like trying to put out like like
sometimes the thoughts you put out like
i
one time i was just like i just watched
something on the news
and it inspired me to write something
without thinking too much
post set and there's a guy named don
winslow who's an author he's
his books have been turned into uh
movies and stuff and he's got a huge
social media following on twitter from
the left
and my com and the thing i posted was
very on the left
so he reposted it and the next thing i
know this
thing that i just kind of threw out
there without really thinking about it
had like 20 000 likes and i was like
holy [__] that's the most likes i've
ever gotten
and and you're absolutely right
in that we don't have to share every
thought and every idea thinking that
it's going to do something for us
because we also don't know which one
of your comments are going to be the
ones that are going to be more
which ironically shows how
we have become more sensitive
you know because it's like especially
with like all the allegations against
comedians
you know there's a part of you that that
like i've
started to pen a tweet you know that
might be like pro mail i guess uh
or like you know come on there's no
evidence those kind of tweets you know
you have these kind of thoughts where
you're just like
you know it's like there's no due
process there's no and then you start
you stop yourself and you go
i don't know if this is i don't know if
i need to put i don't know if i need to
say this to the public i can have these
thoughts with myself and my friends
i don't need to listen you know i've had
friends of ours who have
gotten into trouble and i have for the
most part
reached out and said hey i'm here as a
friend and and you know
i didn't get into the details of it or
anything just letting them know that
i'm you know i'm still their friend um
but as you said
because you have a choice to make
because if you go on social media and
you put it out there
you're not in front of a judge you're
not in front of a court with rules and
regulations you're in this like
jungle it's a mob it's a mob and now you
got to start
trying to explain yourself i mean you'd
be like for me my personal
battle comes with there is a group of
iranian-americans
who are towards the the right-leaning
and they are there's a handful of them
who
who basically feel that america should
somehow go and overthrow
the iranian leadership who are the
mullahs the clergy the
you know the current dictatorial regime
that's there
somehow overthrow them and bring
democracy to iran
now i agree with them on their final
goal which is i
too want democracy for iran i want you
know
human rights i want women's rights lgbtq
rights i mean it's a very oppressive
regime
but i don't agree with their tactic of
somehow having america go
surgically remove just the leadership i
don't know how you'd
bomb or assassinate well they did it
these people
but that's the point they killed one guy
see like they'll point at that they'll
be like oh
they'll say to me like they'll come on
social media sometimes
and they'll say oh you're a sellout and
you support the regime
and there was an organization that i had
uh
you know uh done performances for and
stuff in the past and they've claimed
that that organization is somehow in
cahoots with the government
but really what that organization was
was calling for was diplomacy
which is what the iran deal was and i
personally am anti-war
and i believe in diplomacy whether it's
with iran or iraq or whoever whoever
yeah whoever so and also furthermore i
know that if
a war were to be started between iran
and and america
that i don't know hundreds of thousands
maybe millions of innocent iranians
would have to die
for something to really happen innocent
iranians so anyway all that to say
once in a while these guys will attack
me especially under
trump when trump was talking tough and
he's like i'm going to get a better deal
i'm going to get rid of the regime and
as you said trump's administration kills
this guy soleimani who's a bad guy
and these people go see he's tough he
kills all the money i go yeah but then
what was the plan after that
there was no plan after that i was like
let's kill that guy and then sit back
and see what happens and iran was like
okay now we're gonna
launch some bombs into iraq
and and go after some american soldiers
anyway all of that to say
i don't i i don't agree with them
politically in terms of how
to get rid of this you know totalitarian
regime
so yeah but i what you're talking about
and this is one of my favorite words i
say on the podcast there's actually a
drinking game for it
life is nuanced man yeah you know and
yeah and the internet isn't exactly
exactly so what'll happen is once in a
while these guys will attack
me part of what they do is
they attack anyone who's pro-diplomacy
so there's a lot of
westernized iranians who've grown up
here who are more left-leaning who are
critical of trump
whether they're journalists their uh uh
you know public figures whatever every
once in a while
i'll just be going through my twitter
and one of these guys has
picked up a picture of me at some event
and he's like oh you're part of that
organization and then all of a sudden
they start piling up
and what you just said i'm sitting here
going like do i want to get into an
argument with some
cuckoo on a on an app where it's like
200 characters i got to go back and
forth
how much of my life am i going to put
into trying to convince this person
that i'm not getting paid by the iranian
government
yeah right and so and so similarly when
friends of ours
have been in trouble or when somebody
you know you know you really gotta
you really gotta step back and go do i
want to
jump into this fire right now you know
what i'm saying and get into a little
twitter war with somebody it's not even
about getting into a war it's about just
trying to make a statement because it's
like for some reason
for some reason if you like support your
friend or if you're trying to say
hey you know you're if you if you're if
it turns out your friend has done
something wrong
so now the the mob is telling you that
you have to cut that person off forever
you can't have any kind of empathy
because if you have empathy for your
friend it means that you're pro
whatever you know right whatever the bet
and so then you just kind of go ah
but so i'm saying this isn't for 200
characters
like my empathy i have from my friend
doesn't that does shouldn't necessarily
be
for that and then and similarly though
like even with podcasts you know i've
said things on podcasts and like
you know um on my own podcast or
whatever it's funny like i've had my
my fiance on my podcast a lot recently
because i don't
you know it's hard having guests and so
and it's funny how the same
video and you look underneath you see
the comments so you'll have a comment oh
my god you guys have the greatest
relationship
another comment on the same video man
this is cringe
they they are so uncomfortable with each
other you know and then somebody else
they're so sweet together this is my
relationship goals and so what i that
made me realize i was like oh
you can't i can't try to please that's
the moment where you go look i'm just
being my authentic self this is what it
is
if you want to perceive it the way you
want to perceive it it's fine so what we
have to learn to do what we've had to
learn to do as comics and like
performers is get past
our insecurity which is like we're
rooted in insecurity that's the whole
reason why we became comics and
it's one of them it's the core
underneath psychological thing why we
became comics is insecurity you know
what i mean
it's there all at all times so we just
have to find
ways to just like getting
being okay with not everybody's gonna
like you
yeah well that that that is absolutely
true and as you said earlier
that's been going on forever but back in
the day if they didn't like george
carlin they would have to go to the
stationery store
buy some paper right right right write a
letter
mail it out you know but you're right as
a matter of fact one of the moments when
it really landed for me because early on
under youtube i had this similar
experience i posted something and
someone was like
oh this guy's hilarious and the next guy
was like i love this guy the next guy
was like this guy sucks and then the
next guy was like
you're an idiot now they're arguing and
yeah like what the hell just happened
and and and i uh
i remember watching letterman i think
like lady gaga or somebody was on there
but
letterman was letterman goes uh
oh by the way folks they just made uh
there's free wi-fi
in central park which is great for me
because at lunch time i take my laptop
out there and read all my hate mail
and that's what it donna make a holy
[__] david letterman must get
thousands and thousands of hate mail
you know letters every day because he's
saying stuff
that someone's gonna find insensitive
yeah these late night shows
every night they got to do jokes yeah
it's like pornography though to look at
your
hate your troll comments it's
pornography for us that's what people
don't understand because people tell me
all the time
you give the trolls too much attention
it's like i don't need to give the
people that
get me attention it's these people that
are like you know coming at me like you
know
so
i have kind of like a little bit of a
radar on my mind so
gosh part of social media now is like
when you post something don't just post
it and be like i'm out you got to kind
of
interact a little bit so the algorithm
knows that you're present and then it'll
push it further whatever so
usually when i post something let's say
on instagram for the next 15 20 minutes
i just look at comments and maybe give
it a heart or say oh thank you so much
or whatever
just interact for 15 20. i'm done and um
i have this little you know i have a a a
a a gauge in my head right if so if i
post something
that's you know trying to be funny or
it's a
or it's a a flyer for a show and someone
comes down and
posts either something you know
political
or just like nasty or whatever the
beauty of this
these apps now is you go and it feels
good you go block
you know block delete and i love doing
that because i'm like
get the hell i don't need you in my life
with your petty [__] trolling and i
just get rid of these mofos you know
what
i don't do block i do restrict and i do
mute on twitter
and the reason is is like when you block
somebody you give them a little bit
where they think they got to you so
they're like so then they
repost they repost a picture of like i'm
blocked by mazda bonnie and then they do
that so then they have their whatever
i like restrict i don't know if you know
what restrict does
it lets them think that the post is
there
and only only they see it
hilarious so i feel like
i'm giving i'm letting them have that
outlet they're they're screaming into
the ether
and i think that's great same thing with
mute i just mute people when they say
some
nonsense on uh you know like i had this
this one guy remember
he said he was like you know he looked
at the pocket he's like you know you
don't think trump's qualified and he's
like trying to
get my educational background he's like
where have you been you know
i just i think like that that's like
saying i can't
i can't criticize a movie you know if i
if i can't do the action that the movie
is doing
no i'm gonna say i i can have an opinion
of people doing stuff and being like
i don't think they're doing that well
i'm not saying i can do it i can't do it
either
you know what i mean but i just mute
this guy so that he can continue to talk
he can continue to put his you know
whatever i don't ever see it and the
point of that is for me to see it right
so
yeah i don't know i know what you're
saying though but then i feel i feel
like even that's too much energy when
you go in and you block because then it
turns into a thing too like that's
actually a thing on youtube where you
have these like troller
uh youtube channels who like once you
block a comment they're all over that
oh you're blocking people you're not
letting people get your thoughts out you
know then you turn that turns into a
whole thing too but
you know what my whole thing is like
yeah [__] i'm blocking you
you're out of here like i sometimes take
pleasure and go you're i know what
you're saying because for a minute i was
like ah do i want to like
like you said give them i blocked some
dude
on i don't know what it was he asked
something stupid it was the
same kind of political [__] he asked
something about you know
my political stand and i was like and
the way he asked it because i've also
had people come up to me and be like hey
let me ask you a question you know
um what are your thoughts on you know
all these whatever
yeah and i'm like oh thank you for
asking and respectful well here's my
thoughts
yeah this guy came at me in a kind of
like an aggressive way and i was like
block and then the next thing i know
he's posting on he took it and he posted
something on his
facebook saying oh i asked monster brian
this question and then he blocked me and
blah blah blah
and i'm like who is this guy so i'm
starting to research it a bit and i
usually don't spend too much time on all
this [__] be honest with you it's like
if i see it and if it's like
if it's dirty or something i get rid of
it if it's like harsh like that i just
get rid of it
but this guy's like who is this guy so
then i'm looking at his post and then
underneath his post there's like
different people commenting going yeah i
never liked that guy in the first place
and i'm like who are these people yeah
it's dawning on me more and more
that they just don't like my politics
and i'm like well there's nothing i can
do here
and then it dawns on me as i'm doing the
research because he says i'm like oh i
acted with him
uh on superior donuts and i'm like he
acted and i was like oh my god this guy
was an extra
yeah on the tv show i was on and so he's
one of these guys who's
yeah let's turn it down uh uh uh
you know i like when they say that oh i
was working remember when we worked
together
we didn't work together but but then i'm
thinking to myself god what a dick
because he probably on that set
if he came up to me and said anything i
probably was very nice and was like yeah
you got to do this do that i don't know
i don't know what my interaction was
with with him but i'm always very very
encouraging and
and yeah supportive you give people too
much time and that's why they think they
can do that
but that's the thing so so once this
guy's going that far i'm like dude i go
this guy has nothing better going on in
his life because
listen ultimately end of the day when
you
when you put that phone down and you
look around you and you're like oh
there's trees and grass and my kids
and my wife and a dog and there's things
i'd rather do
so i know you've spent time away from
your phone for like several hours and
you're like god i feel
i feel pretty good i'm almost glad when
i don't see a hateful comment
i hate that like you kind of go back and
go i wish i hadn't
seen that because i thought this was
fine and now i'm in my head you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah no it's crazy
because it's it's this reality
and some people unfortunately live
deeper in it and then there's the
then there's the ones who i've done
stuff before whether it's an ig live or
like a post
where i posted it i'm done i'm not
looking at the you know
it's it's doing really well so it's
getting a lot of comments and i'm like
i'm overwhelmed i'm not going to sit
here look at everyone
then somebody will message me and be
like hey this guy
fred who was commenting on your stuff
was really rude and i said something to
him now he said this to me and i'm like
oh
my god i'm like now you're like now
you're like what are you the principal
you know somebody's coming snitching i
gotta go i gotta go find
fred and ban friend yeah man i had a
thing uh just recently
it's funny you know um guy because what
you're talking about is
this goes back to reiterating what you
said about people being the hero of
their own story
and this is actually a great example of
this you know uh
guy comments under my
video of my lady in my she and he calls
her stupid he was like you know oh she's
so sweet but she's so she's
she basically so i wrote back and i was
like why is this okay
like why do you think that this is okay
you know because sometimes that's the
way to go with it is just put it out
there with people like another another
quick example somebody said to me
like something about like you know when
are you going to tell everybody how gay
you are
you know and then i wrote back i said
why is that a problem for you
you know like if this were true why do
you have a problem with it when a guy
deleted that because then it put it on
him
like some people say that kind of stuff
where they go well you're this and you
go okay
let's say i am uh what's your problem
and now it turns into the people going
like oh you know what you know what i
mean so he just deleted it because it
was just it's just dumb and that's how i
handle it sometimes anyway
schedules i say that to him and then he
writes back a whole story about how
well my son watches you twitch and he
sent you two dollar
couple dollar super chat it's like how
they tip you
and then and then later asked hey can we
can i play a game with you
and i said like why would i play with
you right
and um then he goes in about now he's
trying to justify
him calling my girl stupid because of
this thing that happened with his kid
all right i get it the i'm the hero of
my story
my story is everybody that i play that
are that are watching me wants to play
with me
i get countless messages on here all the
time about
play with me please play with me you
know and so i have to be
i can't i'm not why i can't i don't know
you you know what i mean yeah
like could i could i have said it a
nicer way but if you're watching my
stream i'm being myself you know how i
am this is like you're getting a piece
of me
so if i'm saying to the guy like nah man
like i'm saying to somebody i don't know
who it is i don't know if it's a woman a
man a boy whatever i'm just like why the
please you know it's like it's a real
serious question like and you think and
now i'm looking back like oh so you
think two dollars means i give you all
my time
it's like you know what i mean it's like
yeah so but he's the hero of his story
he's a dad who's trying to stick up for
his kid and it's like i just think like
you're
what are you talking about so that's one
of those moments where you just go like
damn i maybe i shouldn't have even
interacted with the guy maybe i should
have just muted the guy blocked the guy
and been like all right you did
something that i don't appreciate and i
want you out of here
but then try to give people time to try
to be like hey man
why would you do this and they still
come back and try to justify their
stupid behavior
that's the thing about it it's not even
like it's not even like if you would
have said to me
you know what my bad you're right i
shouldn't have
said that but you know what you did
something to me that made me feel this
way
right i saw a guy marcellus wiley he's
on uh speak for yourself he said the
greatest thing about you know that he
learned from going to therapy is that
there's two times you should apologize
when you're wrong and the other time is
when you make someone feel bad right
yeah yeah you know and it's like that
second one is hard
that second one is because we all feel
like we're justified to say and do the
things that we do
yeah well that goes back to what that
being the hero of your own story versus
the
other you know being the villain or or
the second or third character or someone
else's story
i had another guy on my podcast who is
uh
in a throuple it's three three men and
they've adopted two
children and he's a doctor he's very uh
well-spoken
and we ask them we go what
happens when two of you are upset at the
third one
how does that work out and he said you
know we step away
and we take our time we come back and we
have a rule he goes we
we first say um i i thought about what i
said i'm sorry
if it upset you for whatever reason i've
thought about how it affected you they
put themselves in the other guy's shoes
and think about it and come back and
then go and by the way i apologize
and then he said the other person has a
chance to either say i accept it or i
don't
but i think a lot of times in our lives
especially with twitter especially with
social media
we don't empathize we don't put
ourselves
in other people's shoes like you just
said exactly that dad could have come
back and been like
hey man my bad if that made you feel bad
but just so you know i'm lashing out
because of x y z
exactly yeah you probably would have
been like oh man
my bad you know what let's do a special
game day with yourself whatever you
are doing no but i understand like i
understand it's like you know i under
but what i'm saying is
i understand that's the thing i'm saying
like i
understand but everybody has their thing
it's like it just goes back to like when
you have you ever seen
these kind of posts have somebody posted
this about you where it's like
you know i saw maz at a restaurant and i
asked him for a picture and he said no
and he what a dick like doesn't he know
that the fans are
or the reason why he made it like that
kind of train of thought
you know for them they feel so justified
that they don't even think about like
like well i'm eating with my family i'm
on a date i'm on a thing
do i have to be this person for you all
the time and when does it end
so does everybody in this restaurant get
to take a picture with me right now or
is it just you
you know it's like when somebody comes
and goes you know i hate being that guy
but moss can you
how do we stop him and go uh-uh you love
being that guy
right oh first of all eric i never say
no to the pictures that's you buddy so
uh yeah i saw you say no to that poor
kid
wait a minute wait a minute you are
lying through your teeth you do not say
yes every single time no no
no you do not you just don't try to make
yourself look good you kidding me okay
bro
how many how many so if 10 people in a
restaurant you go you're with your
family
no no no no i get in trouble with my
wife because she goes you're a pleaser
because i
agree i agree you do you go too far
remember that time at the comedy magic
club
you letting this guy i'm looking at your
face he's clearly annoying you
he's clearly getting you know and you
you give i tried said to him
hey man okay thank you but we're getting
ready for the show that
there's nothing wrong with letting
people know that they're overstepping
their
bounds you know what i mean they're
overstepping but listen but you're right
though i think people like you said they
they see
they're seeing the world in their way
they feel like you owe them something
um you you made me think of a few things
first of all i don't put my
wife for the most part i don't put her
on my social media because she is
uncomfortable with it as much as my wife
is beautiful and she should be the she
should be the actress in the family and
i should be the lawyer or whatever
the person behind the scenes but she's
just not comfortable with it and
one time you know again persians can be
very racist they can be very and there's
a lot of great great persians there's a
lot of great people from every
background
but i think what happens is when you
make it from a community they feel like
they own you
so i think this one lady one time i
posted something
and some lady like commented like why
would you marry an indian like she's
ugly or whatever
meanwhile i'm like who the who's this
[__] and that pissed me off and i got
me like
practice
from then she was like i don't even want
to necessarily be put out there and i
was like i totally get it and i'm very
respectful of that and
and i try to avoid because i know she's
beautiful and i know she's a great
person but like you said some
[__] just to make a comment is going
to make a comment and then that's just
going to get me all riled up so
i'm telling my my girl right now she's
doing her own vlog now and she comes on
my podcast so she's trying to just think
so i said to her i was like
you have to be ready for the negativity
because it's going to be a lot
because we have an age difference you
know i'm older than her you know what i
mean and it's like
so there's all that it's like go digger
she's out of your league griffin it's
like all these things that we
that we're dealing with but she's taking
it like a trooper because she's been a
model for
15 years you know what i mean so there's
always going to be you know
you you got to have a sense of humor
about it and realize like again when i'm
always funny
on my instagram live sometimes fan
fan fan fan fan troll fan fan fan troll
and that same troll will keep coming
back and then eventually
there's time i don't do them as much
anymore but i'd be doing it
and that troll is just dying for
attention and then all of a sudden
the fans start talking to the troll so
i'm talking talking i see the comments
now they're going back and forth yeah i
know
so sometimes i just i just turn around i
go you know what everybody let's just
stop for a second hey [__] just
shut the like it's fun for me to just
cuss him out and then when he comes back
up i'm like
you're still there okay no more talking
to this guy it's just you
but take it with a grain of salt and be
like i'm moving on from that
so that's one thing which is like
they're going to come at you
and you got to just be like eh whatever
now
the thing about what you were just
saying like once in a while you read a
comment you're like oh
that kind of hurt um so i had my new
special just came out
and obviously when your special comes
out you want people to watch it yeah you
want people to live
so so yes so you so you promote promote
promote
and and then and then once in a while
a random person will come on and be like
hey i saw your oh i just discovered you
this is great you're like oh great
new fan so some girl because the special
was shot mostly in dubai
and by the way by the way i know while
you're talking about this can you
actually because we will end with this
actually i want to want you to talk
about
the special how you felt about it where
you did it what it's called where can
they find it
and uh you know just the whole the whole
process because it is fascinating to
know that you went to dubai
and i've been to dubai with you and
watching how
just beloved you are in that part of the
world so but anyways go on i didn't mean
to cut you off
yeah yeah so i'll i'll i'll end with
that story but but
um what was interesting was so i'm on my
twitter and i and this
and this girl starts her tweet it says
something like just watched major
ronnie's
special on peacock and i was like oh
great another fan
and then she's like it was filmed in
dubai
and it's the utmost ignorance that he's
saying dubai is a great place he didn't
talk about like the
the laborers who've died building those
buildings or something like that i'm
like
[__] yeah you can't
you know what if i go into the details
like that you can't talk about anything
you know what's crazy about that
that would be like then you that would
be like someone going like
uh well america is a great place to live
then you go oh so
you mean slavery you mean the place that
had slavery you mean the place that had
this i mean the place that had not you
know
uh timothy mcveigh the place that you
know like
you could so if you if you thought like
that at all times you could delve into
the details and no one's safe
nothing can be talked about but it's
funny because part of my mind was like
okay well i got one more viewer that was
good i was like at least you watched it
but the other part of me was like
exactly we just said i was like geez
it's a comedy special shot in dubai
so for me to like because then i went on
our patients
like who is she she's like some
activists i was like for me to like
please you with what your agenda is
i would have had to go up in front of an
audience in dubai and be like
you guys hey [__] you guys you
know
you guys are killing people in buildings
now the truth is yes
there's the worker conditions in dubai
there's a lot of issues with it
but that's not what i'm talking about
now but it's a comedy show
and and you missed the the message is
like because part of the message that
that
that came out of the show
unintentionally but it came out of the
show
regardless was when i started doing my
crowd work
every time i talked to somebody they
were from a different part of the world
so there was emiratis you know from
dubai
there was iranians there was americans
there was
um there was turk turkish people there
was uh
cubans there was someone from jakarta i
mean it was international and anybody
who's traveled there as you have
knows that places like uh dubai
and uh doha and some of these countries
that are
relatively young and newly built have
people from all over the world it's a
very international setup so
that was kind of a message that i was
like okay let me put this message out
there so people watching this
in america if they're watching us
somewhere in middle america they might
be like oh i thought they were all
terrorists who wanted to kill us
right right it's a bunch of people
living their lives yeah but dude how
many times have you watched something
like let's say you're watching like say
a black comedian and all of a sudden
they're talking about how terrible white
people are
imagine you know you're white you're
watching it at a certain point you have
a moment of like here we go
you know what i mean yeah it's like
sometimes sometimes that
and that's a fair reaction you know it's
like i'm watching aladdin the new
aladdin the remake
you know yeah and they got this new song
where the it's like
the princess is singing and it's sort of
this like pro feminist like i'm a woman
you know and i was like in the theater
like here we go
because it's like you know it's like
damn you we can't even
even in the disney universe we can't
just you know we can't just have a
a a [__] a vanilla just yeah yeah no
you know it's like so that so there is
that reaction so you know but again
but also an activist
yeah well it goes back to what we said
in the beginning of of the podcast which
is you just got to be your authentic
self and in that case
my message in filming it in dubai was to
show
america that there are people in the
middle east living their lives just
doing their thing and look they laugh at
comedy and there we are like that's been
a big
goal of mine from the beginning of my
career which was to show
people from my background and people
from my similar background
laughing and different than what we're
used to seeing them in steven seagal and
chuck norris movies and whoever else
right the seal team or whatever it is so
it's not the story of it
the story of it goes you know you and i
both know we tour
tour tour right right right you end up
with an
hour hour plus you're like oh my god
this stuff's ready to go it's cooked i
got to do it so
for a while it had been cooked now my
previous special was shot in 2017
it was a netflix special called
immigrant and
that one was shot in
spring of 2017 came out in the summer
shot in dc at the kennedy center
a lot of political stuff in there and
netflix had
actually said we will shoot this so they
gave us you know
the money to shoot it when they pay you
to shoot a netflix special
they go we don't want you to like you
know do a show
in a tiny room and spend ten dollars on
production
and pocket the rest of the money they go
we want you to spend the money on the
production
so look bigger we had the funds we're
ready to go this time around
i'd say for a good year or so at least
year year and a half i felt ready i was
like
i'm ready i'm ready for my next special
now a couple of things came up first of
all you want to call it a special then
you should shoot it in a place that's
somewhat special
so i've done the kennedy center i've
done la
i've done sweden and i'm like what's the
next place what's the next place
so in thinking about it um middle east
came up as one of the places i've never
shot a special i go what about the
middle east okay that's a good idea
then you know we go to netflix and
netflix now is a little
pickier with what they're doing and all
that a lot of us
comedians know that like people think
like oh you should have your next
netflix special
well it's not as easy as you think so
sometimes that you know you go okay let
me just go out and shoot it
myself and then come back and show it
and sell it so
i was touring in the end of 2019 in the
middle east
and it was kind of a last-minute thing i
was like it's been in my mind to shoot
something there
let me hit up my buddy see if we can
shoot something in dubai
and the weather's nice in december so we
were thinking hey let's do an outdoor
like with all the buildings in the
background
let's do or maybe like a desert back
let's do something kind of cool and
different
again you know how it is because we
didn't have netflix behind me going
do whatever you want or some big you
know some network behind me going here's
a ton of money go do it i had to fund it
and we were time constrained so the
producer
originally was like yeah we'll do it
outdoors this this and that then he
calls me up he's like
listen man the outdoor thing's not gonna
work too much noise
this that whatever you know you need
permits he's like but we're gonna build
some tents and i was like well what's
the point of building a tent
but he did it regardless and we filmed
it in this tent in
in in dubai and so production value it
still looks nice but it's not as big as
my previous one
um but more importantly i thought
because i filmed it
december of 2019 and i thought okay i'll
go back home
and in early 2020 i'll go back to
netflix and maybe whoever else the
buyers are
showtime comedy central someone will
pick it up we'll be good to go
well the pandemic hit and then all of a
sudden it's like hold
hold hold and then the thing that was
interesting to me was i
saw a few comedy specials come out
that had been shot before the pandemic
they came out when we were on lockdown
yeah yeah yeah and i'm
i'm watching it i'm like this looks like
they shot it on mars because a bunch of
people are next to each other i know i
know
i know right no one's mask i thought to
myself
i thought to myself this is gonna be
some of the last like are we ever gonna
see this again i kept thinking that when
i was watching like seinfeld and i was
watching i was like oh no
we'll never do this again you know and
and you're sitting there going like this
material is like they're talking about
traffic like
what does that doesn't even exist
anymore and so i realized to myself i
said you know what if i'm going to put
out a special i got to do something
that at least i'm i'm giving a nod and a
wink to say i know what's going on so
what i did was
we got with comedy dynamics and they
sent me
a couple of ipads to set up in my house
this is like under the first lockdown
where everyone was like
make sure you sanitize everything and
keep your distance so it's me
in like a basically a little closet in
my house
with the two ipads and the directors on
the phone
like on facetime and we're doing
mike mike you know coronavirus material
you know so we did that so at the top of
the special when people watch the
special they'll see it's like
three minutes of or five minutes or so
it's like an interest
you know kind of giving you what's going
on and then i go now let's go watch what
i filmed in dubai
yeah then you go and you see that
special and for the most part a lot of
it is
is relatable at evergreen there's some
trump jokes there where you might be
like well he's no longer around
but still that was then and then i come
back at the end and i do a couple more
minutes in the closet so i bookended in
a way which i felt happy with to be able
to go this is what
you can find it on peacock right it's on
peacock which is another thing which is
interesting because again i told them
because there was trump jokes because
there was
some other jokes i was like you guys got
to put this out before the elections
before the elections well
peacock had their own bigger plan which
was to bring
the office to peacock in january and by
the end of january
launch a bunch of comedy specials on
there so if you go to peacock now
they've got like
20 30 comedy specials mine's one of the
originals there's one other
original but i guess they're in the
comedy game and it was pretty cool like
the first night
when uh it was on i was on their landing
page right next to the office i was like
that's pretty cool
so you know well guys like i say check
that out
check out the special and actually look
at his other specials too
and uh once again also shout out uh when
you were talking about
what that you did in dubai and and uh
you know showing people how it's
different you know we that
shout out again to our you know to
ahmedamed for doing uh
you know i'm um just like us which was a
you know common document
documentary i think it's still on
netflix i'm not sure but you guys should
look for that because that's
i went on tour with them with uh moz and
ahmed and and we went out there and uh
you know for showing and that's what i
learned is the reason why i'm bringing
it up
it's like oh yeah these people are just
like us you know what i mean
and so it's like that's what you learn
and um look man i appreciate you uh
being on the podcast
and uh you know i said i'm sending
everybody your way i'm gonna
put all the information below so you
guys check out the links and
support my guy here and you know be your
authentic self
hey man be your authentic self uh
realize you're the hero of your story
but the villain of others so remember to
let you know try and see the world from
other people's uh point of view that's
important be sensitive and hey i
appreciate you eric we've always been
friends and i appreciate you it's always
nice to
even under the pandemic run into each
other at some of these yeah i know that
was great
yeah man it was good to catch up you
know and let you know
i'll hit you up in another few months
and we could just really like really
look at the world again like
we can we can like do a recap of this is
what
trump versus biden this is what the
world looks like you know what i mean
i'm even surprised that we went this
long and we didn't even talk about none
of that stuff because that's what we
talk about a lot when moz and i get
together we love having a back and forth
about
just like different political beliefs
and and where we are in the things it's
because it's so nuanced with the
take a drink it's so nuanced with
another comedian you know
and not everything's black and white
with us which is i really love well
well what i i will say this to end it
all is that um
i've been talking about this like just
and i don't know where we're headed with
biden or whatever but it's nice to
wake up in the morning and not feel
inundated with
a hundred tweets about rosie o'donnell
and then
you know and and and this and you know
uh whatever it is you know uh
uh a you know rocket man or whatever it
is
it's just nice to wake up and be like oh
we have real problems the you know the
we're trying to deal with those things
the earth is melting yes let's talk
about it i was like yes you know
so i'm happy that's good man and uh much
love to your family
and i will talk to you soon my brother
be well my brother be well thank you
what that was my buddy muzz
gibrani be the hero of your own story
that was the message for that right now
be the hero of your own story guys
thanks for being here as always
uh i'm probably gonna be after this
premiere i probably did a premiere of
this or
after you know after you're watching
this make sure you go check me out on
twitch
or just check for me daily you know just
make sure you turn on the notifications
for my
podcast and turn on the notifications
for twitch
so you can catch me live and you know
i'm very interactive
i talk a lot of smack to the chat i'm a
comic
ooh excuse me what's going on heartburn
but anyways
thanks for being here as always
follow me and i appreciate you guys for
your support your likes
i hate i love the love i love the hate
all everything that goes
with being a you know public figure
on the internet it all it's all for it
and and
we'll try to be all of us will try to
be sensitive in our own way
to everyone else and we'll we'll all
figure it out but thanks again
and i will see you next week